top gun maverick it already has made 300
million dollars at the global box office
and it is projected to be number one at
the box office again this weekend you
just saw it right i mean i loved it i
saw it and i was part of those record
numbers but you know e.t has been with
tom cruise from the very beginning and
he's actually not the only top gun star
we have covered from the start here is
when we first met mavericks new recruits
it's my secret weapon and i actually you
know it's hard to act like you can dance
when you know that you can and i felt
bad lying to the audience
that ain't right long before he was
boogying on the beach busting out moves
on the red carpet and slow dancing in t
swift's video miles teller told us about
his hidden talent he was just 24 years
old starring in the footloose remake
when you found out your cast first
reaction uh excited i probably you know
threw my hands in the air i actually did
the play in high school
first play i ever did was footloose
hangman's coming hangman glenn powell's
first time on et was in 2014 he had a
buzz cut at the premiere of his movie
the expendables 3. i mean it's every
guy's dream to be in an action movie so
if you're hanging out with these dudes
as cool as it gets well i said the magic
words
i guess i said the right ones
and
that's all that is a 14 year old
jennifer connelly long before she became
tom's top gun love interest we met her
on the 1985 set of labyrinth
i am uh
five o'clock in the morning going to be
on an airplane to vancouver canada uh
working on a feature up there uh called
the dave earston still
with keanu reeves
jennifer connolly yes jon hamm has
worked with jennifer before that was
2008 he had just won a golden globe for
mad men it was incredibly emotional ten
years later john introduced us to actor
bill pullman's son lewis pullman they
were co-starring with chris hemsworth in
bad times at the el royale and ready to
start shooting top gun i'm very excited
to re-team we actually haven't even
talked about it oh wow we first met jay
ellis in 2013 at the premiere of movie
43 and from grey's anatomy to insecure
we stuck with him even if he wasn't tv's
best boyfriend people could trust me you
guys could trust me i'm trustable look
at me huh and monica barbaro's first et
interview 2016 on the set of unreal
where she told us even though she was
playing a sutras on a dating show
watching them really wasn't her thing i
can't i can't do the dating clothes i
just can't do it it's so sad they're all
so drunk all the time i can't i can't it
hurts my soul
you